Beautiful. Hey guys, welcome to the call for those of you that are just joining. And that's
something else. Aaron, you know what you need to do? Make a comment in the comments that
says, cut on your camera if you want to stay on the call because people are going to join
and not have any idea. So like a good idea. I'll pin that. Yeah, just go ahead and pin
that. Welcome to the call guys. Stoked about what we're going to talk about today. We are,
if you guys can't tell, we're going extremely niche on these topics. We're going very, very
nuanced because this business model is nuanced. There's the high level. And then there's also
the heck. Dude, I got to turn off my notifications, bro. Hold on. I got like all kinds of stuff
coming on, but I've got it. They got, let me just plug this in. But what you'll realize
with this business, what I was saying is that you have the business model, the overall business
model from a high level, build a simple website, rank it, send leads. And then there's so many
nuances and the better you get at the nuances, the more money that you make. And so that's
why we're basically taking this. If you haven't noticed month by month, quarter by quarter,
we're focusing on different steps of the process and going very, very detailed on these steps
of process. So we're still talking about the very first step, which is picking the city
in the niche. But today we're going to talk about the pros and cons of going broad versus
vertical or wide versus narrow, however you want to look at it. So that said, guys, as
always, the reason that we, like I've been saying the last couple of weeks is I think
our, is our fourth call, Aaron, something like, yeah, this is actually our fifth. So
it's our fifth call doing it that this format and I've really enjoyed it. I swear to you
guys, I'd rather have two people on this call that are paying attention than have a hundred
people on a live and Facebook that are not paying attention. So that said, if you guys
stay on this call the entire time cameras on by the end, we're going to screenshot.
We're going to send you guys a digital resource with the notes in like a very easy to digest
manner that you guys can check out. And so then you don't sit there and focus on writing
everything I say down. You can just write down the things that come to your mind that,
Hey, I should do this or here's an idea, that kind of stuff. And then you're going to get
the, the, the digital resource of the notes and kind of the summary of what we talked
about. So that said, keep, make sure once again, keep your cameras on. We want to make
sure that we see your pretty smiling faces. We only let people in here that are serious
about taking action and that's the truth. Okay. So that said, guys, let's get into today's
topic, which is should you go broad or vertical? Aaron, I want to ask you really quick. I didn't
even tell you, I was going to ask you, but when you first started out, I know you probably
know the, what the answer that I would give, but did you start off by going vertical or
did you start off by going broad? Well, I like, and I first found you from this business.
And so I've immediately like adopted your mentality. So it's been that's checked through
the whole time. And that said, it made more sense to get established in a couple, use
one niche, do that a couple of times to get established. Cause it is easier to just stick
with one niche already know rather than transition. There's different keywords, different lingo,
different pricing, all that sort of stuff, different lead flow. And so it seems easier
to get, get your feet wet, get established with a couple deals in one niche. You don't
want to get reliant on that niche, but get established and then move on with what you
did year by year. Yes, exactly. Okay. Good. Good to know. I'm curious in the comments,
what do you guys think is the best option? And I don't want you to tell me what you think
I want to hear. I want to know what you guys think. I want you to either put broad or vertical
broad meaning you try out a bunch of niches, you, you die, you, what's the word you diversify
or you pick an edge and you go vertical. Which do you guys think again? And by the way, some
of you guys might think that you know the answer I'm looking for. And the thing you
don't know about me or you might not realize about me is I change, I change all the time
because I'm constantly growing and evolving in business. So my answer, you think that
I might be giving you guys, I think some of you guys think you already know what I'm about
to talk about. I might change. I might shock you with the answer I'm going to give you
today because things change, man. Business changes. What worked in 2020 doesn't necessarily
work today. So I am curious in the comments and Aaron, I want you to read the comments.
I've got kind of my notes pulled up here. So I can't really see the comments and I want
to be going back and forth. But let me know what people are saying, narrow or broad.
Yeah. So a paper bully says vertical. So I can focus on building a system. Okay. Kind
of like what I was just saying. Yeah. Depends in France. Theo says I diversify. Okay. That's
interesting. Maybe there's limited cities. So you kind of got to go into different niches
for the bigger cities. Broad in a good city. Shane thought that. No, let me see. Discord
users said too early in my journey. I'm tempted to try broad and local area to start. So yeah.
And then we got one more from Zoom users who said broad to see which niche I vibe with.
Okay. That's interesting. Cool. Okay. Good. All right. That said, one quick thing I should
have started with this. You guys shouldn't listen to what I'm saying. You guys, if you're
brand new to whether it's a Facebook group, the discord channel, and that's how you found
this, you should be asking yourself who the heck is this guy? Why should I listen to him?
And so just my one minute reason why you should potentially consider listening to me is guys,
I've been doing this for a long time. It's been over eight years. Now there was, I always
throw this in because I don't want to make it seem like what it's not, but there was
a eight, nine month period that I had shiny penny syndrome and chased a software company
that completely failed. But for the most part of that eight years, I've been doing this
business model. I spent $1.45 million on ads. I haven't recently checked it, so I don't
know if it's more, but that's the last time I checked. I went $60,000 in debt. I almost
quit twice. I did the wrong revenue model. I did pay per lead, which I think is completely
the wrong way to do it for a couple of years. I've done everything wrong. And I finally
figured it out in 2020 and realized that in order to scale this business, you need
to presale. That's just how it is. And I know some of you guys are like, Hey, I'm just going
to build it. I'm going to do it the slow way. Guys, the slow way of building a website and
ranking it and then going and selling it is, I don't love this word, but well, I'm not
going to use that word, but it's just stupid. It makes no sense. And the analogy that I
always use, I was talking to one of my friends that's in this business, you going and building
50 websites and then ranking them and then trying to sell them, that is equivalent to
you going and building, let's say 50 or a hundred, whatever, the same amount of houses,
say 50 houses. Imagine going and building 50 houses and realizing that you forgot to
put in toilets. It's so dumb for you to go and do that. And by the way, just so you know,
if you're getting the advice, you should go build 10 or 15 or 20. I would bet the people
giving you that advice are also selling you the tools to build websites. Just a wild guess.
They're probably selling you all kinds of services, tracking numbers, or maybe they're
doing hosting or they're white labeling something. It's in their best interest that you build
more websites. I don't sell any of those services, so I don't care. And I'm telling you right
now, do not go and build a bunch of websites and try to rank them. And this isn't even
what we're talking about, David. We want a little rant here because what you don't know
right now, because you're brand new to this or you're not into this enough, that just
because you build a website does not mean it's going to rank. I have built websites
that have never ranked because it was too competitive. I didn't know what I was doing.
Just because you build a website and it ranks does not mean you're going to get leads. I
had a website in Lincoln, Nebraska in a specific industry, didn't even think to check a certain
search volume and all that stuff. Dude, I never got any leads. I was ranked number one
for all the keywords. There was no business there, right? Now that one, you usually are
smart enough, but I wasn't. Just because you get a website ranked, you get leads, does
not mean you're going to find a hungry business owner. I don't know how long you guys have
been in this business, but for those of us that have been in it and for a minute, we've
all had that situation where you build a website, you rank it, you're getting leads, and you
for the life of you cannot find somebody to take the leads. You couldn't give them away
because everyone in that city is fat and happy and they're just getting tons of leads. There's
a ton of leads or there's not a lot of competition and they're the big dog in town and they're
really not motivated to pay you for leads. So you just went and spent six months all
this time, wrote the content, paid your employees, and now you can't sell it to a business owner,
right? And so what if in a different universe, my universe, you could go, you could spend
a couple bucks on ads, you could go in, land the deal, get the business owner, know that
there's going to be lead flow, make sure the business owner's hungry, put the deal together,
get the contract, get the credit card, recoup your costs and use their money to build out
the property. And while you're ranking over the next six to eight months, be making money
the entire time. No fool, even a fool would say that's a much better option. So just so
you guys know, that is how you scale. If you guys think you're going to scale by building,
you know, and then by building websites and then renting them, then you haven't been doing
this long enough. And the reason I even figured this out was by force is because I sat there
and I was like, I need to make a hundred thousand dollars a month or I want to, and I'm not going
to keep doing this business unless I can make a hundred thousand. And I started doing my projections
and I started doing my spreadsheets and I started going, all right, it's going to cost me how much
for the hosting, how much for the tracking numbers, it's going to take me how long to rank.
And I've got employees and I've got content, I've got this, I've got that. And statistically
looking at my websites, only 30% or 50% of them actually work. And then I got to sell them all.
And I started doing the math and it just didn't make sense. I was like, I'm going to have to go
another 20 grand in debt and wait six months before I can even start selling these websites,
guys. And that's what I'm like, dude, this isn't going to work unless I can pre-sell.
And that's it. And that's why the big construction companies do exactly this. I was just, you guys
know I'm in Dubai or maybe you don't, I'm in Dubai. I was at dinner with a friend on Saturday night.
He's like, dude, I'm going to this, he's like, I'm going to this presentation tomorrow. I'm like,
okay. It's actually today. He went this morning. He's like, I'm like, what's it for? He's like,
well, there's this company and it's a company called EMAR. It's one of the largest, it might
be the largest or if not one of the largest construction companies in the world. And basically
he's like, you go in there, they're taking everyone's money upfront. You pay for the project
and you pay your down payment. And then every six months you make a payment and then it's
going to be done in two years. And by the time it's finished, it's going to be worth more than
you bought it for. So I'm like, dude, that's really smart for you because you don't have to pay
everything upfront. Plus it's going to be worth more, but it's even more smart for the company
because guess what? They're pre-selling the building. They're literally raising capital
from you, the user. They're saying, hey, I'll build this house once you agree to pay me for it.
It's genius. So if the biggest companies in the world, EMAR that's in Dubai, that's built half
this freaking city is doing this. Don't you think there's a lesson to be learned? And actually,
funny enough, I've been doing this for years and I just barely heard this on Saturday and I made
the connection. I'm like, huh, even these guys are doing it. So if there's just a little bit of
a reason why maybe you should listen to me. And if you hear me just going off on these rants,
it's because I've been doing this long enough that I've made the mistakes. I'm really just stupid,
to be honest. And that's why I go and I make all these mistakes and I lose this money. And I'm like,
oh, yeah, that's a good idea. Maybe I should try this. So that's why I'm here. Instead of you
going and touching the stove and making sure it's hot, I could tell you it's hot telling you right
now there's things you need to do. There's things you shouldn't do today. I'm going to do that exact
same thing. So my goal for today, guys, is I want to give you all the pros and cons of going both
broad and vertical. And I'm going to give you enough information that you can make a decision
on which one you are going to choose as you start building your digital real estate empire, or as
you continue to build it if you've already started. Now, one little caveat I want to mention
is I am going to do my best to cover as much as possible. And I do want to leave time for Q&A
because I haven't been doing a good job of that. But I'm going to give you most likely enough
to get started. I can't cover in the next 45 minutes enough that you have all the information
that you can go and make millions of dollars. The reality is I can't.
I'm here to give you enough to get started and to give you some inspiration to get started and
take your first steps. And so I'll use this analogy because I could literally spend 10
hours talking about this one subject today because I've been doing it for so long.
So it's kind of like this. I'm the guy I'm going to give you enough confidence that you're going
to go buy a pair of gym shoes and you're going to get into the gym and you're going to know
enough to not feel stupid. You're going to be able to walk around, know how to do bench press,
do a couple biceps, whatever. That's what I'm doing on these calls. I'm going to give you enough
that you don't feel stupid and you have enough like, okay, let me get started. But you cannot
expect to go into that gym to know exactly, I want this body, which muscle should I work out?
How should the sets be laid out? How should I do supersets? Should I not do supersets? Should I
do this? Should I be humble with my rest days? What's my diet? You can't expect to know that
unless you go and hire a trainer. So that said, guys, those people like me, a couple years ago,
I was like, I want to get the best shape of my life. I went and found somebody that had the body
I wanted my age and was completely natural, hired them, spent 20 grand sick. I literally got six
zoom calls with this person and it changed everything the way I was. I was doing everything
wrong. And I've been training for at that point over 10 years, 12 years, and they completely blew
my mind. They gave me information that they spent 10 years getting. So I want to tell you this up
front, because if you guys want the actual exact stuff, then you got to hire the trainer. That's
why we have the digital landlord program. But I want to give you enough to get started to have
enough confidence to just put one foot forward and get going. Okay. So here's going to be the
outline today. And I am going to leave time for Q&A. I'm going to cover what exactly I mean by
broad versus vertical. We'll go really quick on that because most people know what I'm talking
about. I'm going to cover my experience doing broad first and then doing vertical. I'm going
to talk about why life and this business is not black and white and varying shades of gray. And
you'll know what I mean when I get to that. I'm going to talk about exactly what I did to scale
and then I'm going to talk about the sweet spot and how is that digital resource.
So let's do this. Aaron, at any point, if we have questions that seem relevant, please let me know.
Is everyone still good? Aaron, can you hear me?
Yeah, everything's great. Everyone's turned on the cameras. It's awesome to see everyone's
faces. I'm just messaging this person who just joined. Love it. Love it. Love it. Love it. Okay,
guys, let's get into it. So what do I mean by, and I want to keep this to 20 minutes tops,
maybe 15. I want to leave Q&A. So guys, if you have Q&A, if you have questions you want to ask,
start prepping them. You could literally throw them in the comments right now so you don't forget
and I'll try to get to as many as possible. So I'm going to keep this less than 20 minutes. What
do I mean by broad versus vertical? I'm going to keep it short. Broad is wide. Vertical is narrow.
Broad means you decide to go into a bunch of different niches and vertical or narrow means
you go into one niche and you go into a bunch of different cities. Okay, that's it. Very, very
simple. Broad I think can be determined by or defined as two things because you could do a bunch
of different niches in multiple cities or you could do a bunch of different niches in the same
city. Okay, so that's what I mean by broad versus vertical. So let me tell you guys about my
experience with doing broad first and then vertical. So when I got into my first training program,
I learned a lot by the way and I needed it to get going. This is back in 2016. I wasn't ready to
get it. I didn't even know I was buying it and then I was like, you know what, rather than trying
to figure it out, whatever. So I bought it and I got this advice that I'm going to tell you,
which I think is the wrong advice. And the reason it was the wrong advice is because it was outdated
advice. And the reason it was outdated advice is because the person that created the program
was not in the business. And that's why I'm always so adamant about letting you guys know I am still
in this business. I am literally, I was just on the phone with Francesca on Saturday, Saturday
at 9 p.m. before I met this guy for dinner. I was just talking about, I was on a call with Francesca
and she was doing a sales call, right? And then we were talking about, she's got, we're still
doing this, man. We're still literally in this business because if we're not, how the heck am
I going to train you guys? So I got this advice from this first training that I bought and they
said go and build 10, I think it was like 10 websites in 10 different niches. That was the
advice. Go build 10 websites in 10 different niches. So that's what I did. I went and built
10 different websites in 10 different niches. Now I didn't do it right away because I was busy
and everything else, but I did not build two websites in the same niche until I had tried 10
different niches, okay? So my first one was towing. My second one was this service called
crawl space encapsulation. No, yeah, that was my second one. Then I built, did carpet cleaning.
Then I did landscaping. Then I did, I'm trying to even think. I mean, they were terrible. Really,
really bad ideas. So I can't even remember the other five, but I just did a bunch, right?
And at the time I was living in Alabama. I was living in Huntsville, Alabama, knocking door. So
my first five, three to five were in Huntsville, Alabama, right? Which means that my due diligence
process was terrible because one of the chances that it's low-hanging fruit and not competitive
in the same city, zero. And then when I moved back to Utah, after I got done with that job,
I built the rest of my five in that city. So I didn't know what I was doing, but I got this
advice, build 10 niches, try them out, see what you like, whatever. And I think one of the people
that made a comment said that they want to try it out and see what they like. My advice to that is
I don't care what I like. I like what makes money. Now, you don't have to be like me.
If you want to make sure that you love the niche and you're interested in the niche and it's
whatever, that's more important to you than the money that you make, then that is completely
okay. But for me, I like what makes money. And that's why I do this business. Because even though
building simple websites and renting them out isn't as cool as telling people I do jet rentals
or I do jet charters or I sell Rolex watches or I sell cigars, it's kind of like sexy business.
You know what's sexy about this business? Not working for a month and making a hundred thousand
dollars in a month. You know what's sexy about this business? Deciding you're going to go to Dubai
when you're in Vegas with your friends and driving to LA and taking a direct 16 hour flight to Dubai
to stay for a month and business as usual. That's sexy. So I don't care what the business is. I
don't care what the niche is. If it makes money, I'm passionate about that. That's just my take.
I did the broad thing and my experience in it is that I spent the entire time
learning and relearning all these different niches and I could never become the expert.
It was always really tough. I never got the confidence because the first one I got was
towing. And it was really tough to take my confidence from getting the towing deal
and be like, yeah, but I did this for towing. It's going to work for crawl space. It's not as
easy as if I would have got the towing and then went into another towing and then another towing
and I would have been able to show example after example after example. My experience is I wasted
a lot of time learning new niches and I never became the expert and I was never able to build
momentum because I didn't know the lingo and I didn't know the gossip within. You guys,
it's funny. Even inside big business, even inside industries, there's like gossip and there's big
names and there's rumors and there's scandals and there's all kind of stuff. And when you know these
little things, dude, it goes so freaking far and there's conferences and there's marketing
companies that are always called the same companies and you know these little things by being inside
of one industry. So in my experience, doing the 10 niches did not work well for me. Then what I
tried to do is I tried to do one niche in 10 different cities. Now because I'm so not that
smart sometimes, I did this. I'm thinking I'm going to do one niche in 10 different cities.
I got the wrong niche. So if you're going to do that, make sure you got the right niche
because at the time I didn't have someone telling me, hey, go into a tried and true niche
and build in 10 different cities. In my opinion, out of the two, I would rather you
choose a tried and true niche and build in 10 cities than choose 10 different niches.
That's just my opinion. But I did, I was like, cool, I'm going to build in the same niche,
10 different cities. Except for guess what, Nick, you forgot to make sure the niche was right. And
I went to do a niche called foundation repair and it was an accident and one of them worked and the
next nine did not. And not only did I go into 10 different cities, I went into about 50 different
cities. And this is one of the things that really got me into debt because I thought I was in this
really good niche. Meanwhile, I was in an uber competitive niche that I was getting my tail
kicked in. And that was a couple deals away from going into debt, which is exactly what happened.
And I went $60,000 in debt. Okay. Finally, what I realized between doing these two extremes is
that it's actually a combination of both that matters. It's about finding the right niche
and then going into the right cities. Okay. But based on the experience that I just told you,
I would much rather you go into a boring tried and true niche, a concrete tree surface, artificial
grass, masonry, fencing, you know all the ones that talk about duck cleaning, go into 10 cities
is a much better strategy than going into 10 niches. Okay. That's just my two cents. Okay.
But also I'm the kind of guy that's like, I wouldn't go and build 10 right out the gate either.
I'd go and get 10 deals by using the pre-selling method. Okay. So that was my experience. And by
the way, here in just a second, I'm going to get to what I would do today because I don't know if
it would be the exact same. The other thing I want to cover really quick is that guys, I used to
think that life was just black and white, right? There's good people. There's bad people. There
was rich people. There was poor people. There was the right and wrong answer to everything.
And then what you learn as you get older or as you get, I guess, burnt or as you get, I don't
know, but you just learned that life is just varying shades of gray. Okay. And so the answer
that I'm going to give you at the end is not going to be either or, just as a little teaser. I'm going
to give you a bit of a hybrid, if I may. Okay. So one thing I want you guys to just remember is
that there are other factors that come into play. So for example, I would never advise anyone to go
into California, any part of California. However, if you live in California and you have family
members that have businesses in California, you may be able to go into California and make money,
right? But that's a one-off. So I just want to remind you guys that whatever I'm saying today,
it's not black and white. There are varying shades of gray, and you may have a situation that makes
you uniquely equipped to do something that maybe the rest of us can't, right? You may be a turf
supplier that supplies turf to, or your salesperson or supplier, whatever, that sells turf to local
contractors, in which case you have a completely different competitive advantage than we do. But
so I just want to point that out that like it's not completely black and white. Okay. So one more
thing I want to talk about, and then I'm going to get into what I would do today in the last 10
minutes is, guys, what I did when I scaled, this is in 2020, things have changed, things do change,
but what I had to do is in 2020, I had to get very simple. I had to get very focused. I had to get
very dialed in. And so for me, because my brain, I can't really focus on a bunch of things at once.
I do better if I know I'm going to do this one thing and I'm going to do it very well. I'm going
to do it again and again and again, and I'm just going to get good at it. That's how my brain works.
I had to just literally focus on one niche that was tried and true. And in 2020, that was Tree
Service for me. And I had to spend all of my time focusing on how do I pre-sell? How do I set up
ads and get people to pay me before I actually build a website? A, and then B, how do I actually
have a formula to know that this specific city for Tree Service, I have a 97% confidence that I
am going to be able to rank within three to six months? That was what I focused on. One niche,
how do I pick, how do I develop a formula that is tried and true with a 97, 95% confidence? And then
how do I pre-sell? That's what I focused on. I had to go into one niche. And to be honest, guys,
you guys know my story or maybe you don't, but I think I shared a little bit of it earlier.
That was what allowed me to go from barely making money, barely paying the bills,
$8,000 to $10,000 a month to eight months later, July of 2020. I remember I was sitting at Lake Powell
and my brother-in-law was like, how's business? And we're actually camping. Now we aren't even
on a houseboat, which is awful by the way. It's sandy, it's windy, but I remember just sitting
there. And while I was at Lake Powell, I had my two sales guys at the time had both closed a deal
for a thousand bucks each, 250 bucks a week. I'd gotten two new deals. And if I annualize that out,
thousand bucks times 12, 12,000 bucks times two, I put $24,000 in new revenue into my business. And
I wasn't even there. Things were going well. And yeah, I remember telling him, I was like, yeah,
dude, I think they're going really well. And I did the math and I was like, dude, we did $100,000.
Like we're going to do $100,000 this month. And it was in July that we actually did $100,000.
So that's how quickly this changed. Now that was in 2020, knowing what I knew at that point
with the experience I had in business. And so what I want to cover last in this next eight minutes
before I get into Q&A is the sweet spot. And if I were to start today, knowing what I know now,
what would I do? Would I go broad? Would I go vertical? Would I do a combination of both?
And yeah, anyway, and this is what I'm going to tell you is I think that there is a sweet spot.
I think that there is, I don't think you should do either. I don't think you should just do
one niche. I think that there's kind of a combination. And the reason why I'm saying
this is because, you know, I just went into tree service and it worked, but luckily tree
service is an industry. I didn't even think about this. Luckily tree service is a service where
heaven forbid you have a tree falling on your house. But if you do, whether the economy is
good or bad, you got to get it taken care of. You just have to. The other thing in 2020 is
unknowingly I went into cities that didn't have extreme weather. Does that make sense? I didn't
go into, you know, Minnesota and North Dakota and all this stuff where my business completely,
you know, changed during the winter. And so I'm trying to just look at this and let you guys know
it wasn't because I was so good. It was because I did a couple of things right. And then I got
lucky on the rest. I went into the right cities unknowingly. And I mean that like in the right
climates. I picked the right niche unknowingly. Imagine if I had picked a niche that was kind of
tied to the economy. Imagine in 2020 I had picked pool installation. By the way, I don't know if you
guys knew this, but like pool installation in 2020, 2021, I think even into 2022, dude, it was
unbelievable. Unbelievable. Fiberglass pools, shotcrete pools, everybody was getting a pool
because guess what? Not only were they getting stimulus checks or whatever, PPE loans, whatever
we were getting, but also the interest rates were so low everyone was taking out a HELOC on their
house and throwing in a pool. Imagine I had built my business on pool installation. Guess what would
have happened by the end of 2022? My business is gone because nobody's putting in pools now. And of
course people are putting in pools. I'm saying relative to what was happening in 2020, nobody
is putting in pools. My entire street, I think out of like the 20 houses, there's two that don't have
pools. It was insane. I couldn't even sleep after like 6 a.m. because we had jackhammers because we
live on like a mountain, like on a rock and they had to drill through the rock. So I want you guys
to understand that it's not black and white. Just because that worked for me in 2020 does not mean
that if you go into tree service today and today is only tree service, it's going to work the exact
same. It's not. So I just have to let you guys know. The other thing is you have to realize there's
unforeseeable things like the economy. I didn't anticipate the economy was going to do what it's
doing right now. And if I would have gone into pools and built my entire business on that,
gosh dang, that would have been tough. So I like the idea of a bit of diversification so that
I can guard myself against unforeseeable things like law changes, economy factors, etc. Again,
these are things I've learned by being in this business for eight years. And also we can kind
of like extract, if you kind of like zoom out a bit and you can relate this to business in general,
right? Because I stuck with one business and I just went in, I've been in one business and
I've been focusing on one business instead of eight. Yes, at times I've got shiny penny syndrome.
I've been able to scale this one business to make millions of dollars and I've got friends that have
eight businesses, 10 businesses, three businesses, four businesses that are making a quarter of what
I'm making even though they've got more businesses, right? So keep in mind that this principle I think
applies as you zoom out as well to business in general, okay? Here's what I would do. If I
was starting today, I would go into, for your first two to three deals, I would go into one niche and
I would make sure that that niche was tried and true, okay? One niche, tried and true. And when
I say one niche of tried and true, it's the ones I always talk about, okay? Concrete, tree service,
spray foam, artificial grass, masonry, fencing, da da da da da. They're tried and true. You know
they're going to work. You know they're going to, once you get leads and you get a good city,
it's going to work. Until you get two to three deals, you should not be changing niches. You
should just go get two or three deals. And the reason I don't just say one is because if you get
one, you may as well get two or three because you've already learned all the keywords for that niche.
You already have learned the lingo and what the good services are, where the money is made,
and you can name drop, and you can use the momentum to get two or three. So my recommendation,
what I would do if I was going today is I'd go one niche for my first two to three deals, okay?
That's step one. And that would be in a tried and true, boring niche. Step two is that I would go
into two to three boring niches. So I might expand out a bit. So, okay, let's say I got three tree
service sites. Now, just to diversify a bit, I might add another boring niche. I'm not going
to go into freaking yacht rentals right out the gate. I'm not going to go into assisted living,
which, by the way, assisted living is terrible. I've never done yacht rentals. I'm just giving
you examples. But if you do want to expand, you could also just stay in one niche and go to 10k,
get out of your job, whatever. But to diversify a bit, what I would do is I would add one or two
niches. I'd have max three boring niches. And I would learn everything about those two to three
niches until I get enough deals to get to 10k. And 10k being representative of the amount of money
to live. Because usually at 10k net, you could pretty much pay your bills. Now, some of you guys
live really lavishly, maybe not. Some of you guys, that's probably way more than you need.
But I would stick in the two to three niches until I hit enough to pay my bills comfortably.
And this is my main thing. Because I'm guessing most of you guys, maybe not all, but most of you
guys are probably still working a job, doing other stuff. Maybe it's another business and
you're trying to make this your main thing. So step one, one niche for your first two to three
deals. Step two, either keep scaling that one niche or diversify into two to three niches tops
until you get out of the rat race, until your bills are paid, until you get to 10k, until you
get to a comfortable number where you're not strapped, where you're not scared. You can quit
your job with confidence. Okay. Step three is I would keep scaling those two to three niches
and I would focus on those two to three niches only. And I would not go and test other niches
because now you've already done the work. You've got the keywords, you know, the lingo, you know,
the rumor, you know, the gossip, you know, the companies, the vendors, everybody uses,
you know, what the conferences are, you know, the good times, you know, the bad times, you know,
when it's slow, you know, when it's hot, you know, when people are spending their money on their tax
dollars on doing the service, you know, everything about these niches, why would you go change?
Okay. I'm not changing. I'm not going out of three, three max is my, if I'm doing this today,
I would not go above three until I get to at least $50,000 a month, at least 50k per month.
And guys, I wouldn't test another niche. Even if I'm making $25,000 a month net and I have the
money to spend, I'm a single person. I don't have bills to pay. I don't got baby mama drama and
child support and all these different things that some of us have to do. I still would stick to what
you know. And the only time I would test a new niche, the only time I would never do it on my
own, I would do it when referrals came in. I've talked about this at length, but as you guys stay
in business, this is another great thing about staying in business is as you guys continue to
do this and you're the leads guy, you're the guy that knows how to get business and get the phone
to ring, you start getting people sending you messages. You start getting your clients that
you're doing a really good job for calling you saying, Hey, my brother's in this business over
here. Can you get him leads? When you get those referrals and those are in different niches,
that's a really good time to test different niches. And so instead of me going, Hey, I'm going to try
a yacht rental. I got a call from, I'll give you an example. I had a client I was doing masonry for
in Phoenix, Arizona. Okay. And it was a sub niche of masonry and we crushed it. They're paying us
like a thousand bucks a month and they let us know, we had no idea. They let us know after a while,
they had this other business called cactus removal. And I remember my sales guy called me. He's like,
Hey, he wants cactus removal, removal leads. And I'm like, what? Who knew that was a business
cactus removal? Literally you go and remove cactuses, right? This is why this, this by the
way, guys, side note, this is why this business is never going to be saturated. Cactus removal,
cactus rule, right? And dude, I never would have even thought of it. A B I would have never spent
my own money to go put up a landing page and run ads. And no, absolutely not. Right. However,
I told my sales guy, I said, okay, well, we have no idea what's going to happen, but you can tell
him that if he wants to run the risk, we're going to do the exact same strategy. We're going to own
the website, the whole deal. He's going to need to help us with images. He's going to need to
help us with an address, all that stuff. And it should work, but we've never done cactus. And
that's the truth. And so, you know, and it's probably going to cost a little bit more because
it looks like, you know, we're going to have to learn the this and that and the rest and our team's
going to have to learn the keywords. And so I basically told my sales guy to quote him high.
And so for the masonry deal, we were making like a thousand bucks a month. And he went back to,
by the way, I remember I was on the golf course. I even remember the golf course. I even remember
the exact hole because my sales guy threw me off when he told me cactus removal. And I was like,
what? Because we were trying to hit a goal as a company. And I was like, you know what,
just give him this offer. And he calls me back by about like the eighth or ninth hole. We were just
finishing the round. And he's like, he said, yes, he's in. And I'm like, dope, let's do it. I'm like,
have the team build it. And guys, the crazy part is, is we took the money up front. We had him pay
for the full first month. It was like 1200 bucks. I think it was. And I could be wrong. So it might
have been 1500. It might've been 1100. I don't know. It was over a thousand. And we took the money. We
used his money to build the website, to buy the domain, to build the content. We used his photos,
all that stuff. He basically did everything for us and we own the property. And guys, that property,
that project crushed it. It absolutely crushed it. We got leads left and right. There was no
competition. We ranked quickly. We didn't have to spend that much on ads. And it was just freaking
gravy. And I had no risk, right? I didn't have to go and do my research on, oh, his practice.
He wanted the leads bad enough that he was willing to give us money up front. And I'm like, yeah,
I'll educate myself on your dime. And I did that because I would have been willing to make
zero dollars to know that that niche was not good. Okay. However, keep in mind, the principle
behind this is I did not seek it out. I did not say, you know, I'm not satisfied with these two to
three niches that are making me all this money. I need to go look at another one. No, I waited until
I got that phone call until my sales guy talked to him enough that he's like, yeah, can you get
me cactus removal leads? And I was like, yeah, same thing. Guys, you want to know how I got into
artificial grass? I didn't go into a new niche. I was still comfortable, man. I was doing concrete.
I was doing tree service. Tree service was in, uh, tree service was in 2020, 2021. I was still
kind of doing tree service. Um, and yeah, still doing, honestly still doing tree service. But at
the beginning of the year, I had somebody come to my house to give me a quote for artificial grass.
And they asked me if they could, if, if I could get them leads, that was the only reason that I
went into it. And it ended up being a phenomenal niche in 2020, 2021. I made a lot of money on
artificial grass, but I didn't go and look for it. That's like being in a relationship you're
super happy with and everything's flowing. You're like, dude, I'm going to, I'm going to go, I need,
I need to go get a side chick or side guy. Like it's stupid, right? You're, you're,
you're self sabotaging, right? That's just my two cents. So step one, one niche to get your first
two or three deals. Step two, you can expand into two or three boring niches, but pick them wisely
and keep them boring. And when I say boring, tried and true, because you know, they're going
to work and learn them and perfect them and be in those, make them everything to you until you get
to at least those two to three. Like I'm sticking in those until I get to 50 K. Okay. And I'm not
going outside of it until somebody approaches me. Okay. And guys, another thing is as you crush it
for your clients, they're going to refer you to people. They're going to want you to get leads
for their other businesses. They're going to want to tell their, they're going to tell their friends,
their family about you. You are going to get deals if you take care of your clients. Okay.
And then lastly, I put this is like, once you guys get to 50 K plus, if you want to go test new
niches for the fun of it, go do it. And I did do a bit of that. Like I went into golf lessons,
I went and got a golf lesson. I was like, I wonder if this would work. And I did golf lessons.
I got leads. It just, it wasn't enough. It wasn't that the margins were that great. The guy wasn't
super hungry. It was just kind of fun. I did assisted living because my brother-in-law was
in assisted living. He's like, Hey, I think we could do this. There was, I think there were
some regulations. We didn't really do much with that. I think I spent like a thousand bucks
testing that out. I tried, what else did I try out? I tried out some interesting stuff
that a lot of it didn't work to be very honest with you. But once you get to 50 K plus, I think,
okay, you're fine. You want to go do some stuff for fun. Great. But still, as I look at that,
I still didn't really make that much money. It's always better when you have a hungry customer
come to you because you already have the customer in the bag. Now you just have to go with the leads.
Okay. So that said guys, that is the sweet spot. That's how I would attack it today.
Now, the thing that we've talked about in previous lives, these Monday lives, we talked about how to
pick the perfect city, which by the way, we're not talking about today because I've covered that
before. But if you don't, you could do all this and you pick the wrong city. You're screwed. You're
screwed. Right. That's what I did. Right. I was going and I didn't know what the right city was.
And I went and built in all kinds of different cities and I wasn't making money. So this business
model, although it's simple, build a website, get leads, whether that's through SEO, whether that's
through ads, get a client and set it and forget it mailbox money. Although it's simple from like
an a 20,000 foot view, there's a lot of nuances. Like guys, we're talking about just the topic of
broad versus vertical today. And I'm just getting warmed up. But for the sake of Q&A,
I want to go into that. So what we're going to do now, guys, is I told Aaron,
because we're going to start doing this for those of you that are on this call and you're like,
like I was when I got into this business, I didn't have time to waste.
I absolutely did not have time to waste. I wasn't interested in trying to piece
all this together. I told Aaron to have the link ready. So Aaron, in the comments, if you want to
drop the link, I'm only saying this because I know that there's going to be that one, two,
three people on this call that are like, Hey, this is great. I want to go fast. I want to get
out of my job. I'm tired of it. I was at that point. And so for those people, if you guys want
to apply, that's the link to digital analysts. You don't have to go find it. I was in the situation.
I'll just let you know this, that I got, I knew I wanted to do this model, but I was probably like
a lot of you guys. I was like, I'm going to do it after I get done doing door to door sales this
summer. That was my goal. That was my plan. I'm going to go make money. Guys, I got to Alabama
and my license to knock doors was expired. It hadn't been approved and I couldn't knock,
like legally couldn't knock. So I had to go with my manager, my co-manager, we co-manage his team.
And I basically had to shadow him. I couldn't even pitch like legally. I was running the risk
of getting in trouble. So I shadowed him the very first day. Didn't make any money. I'm
shadowing this guy. And I remember about two hours in, two hours into my very first day,
I had four or five months ahead of me of knocking door six days a week. I knew I was like, I'm not
going to make it unless I get, unless I get something going right now, I'm not going to
mentally make this for the next four or five months. I'm just not. And that day I went home
and I started watching videos and I started, I'm like, I have to do this. And within a week,
I'd been on a call and I was going through training and I was spending my, I spent my entire summer
knocking doors, doing my job and building websites, learning how to build websites,
learning how to do content and just trying to figure this out. And it sounds exhausting
because I didn't have that much time or energy, but it was so fun because I could not,
I could not even fathom how fun it would be, how exciting it would be to be able to not knock doors
and just make money from my laptop. That, that idea of that drove me so much. I stayed up till
midnight every night and just worked on my stomach, on the floor, on the carpet. After I ate my
chipotle and showered and I was just learning and it was fascinating. I could, I could make money
from my computer. Are you kidding me? So for those of you that are in that situation, Hey,
I'm done with my job or my situation or whatever. There's the link Aaron dropped it. And that said,
guys, let's go through Aaron. I'm going to have you read any of the questions just because I don't
want to distract my mind. Is there any questions that we need to cover? Yeah, for sure. So let me
quickly just say, by the way, Arunava, he's talked, asked if he could have the recording for,
I think he's talking about the previous slide. We're not giving out those recordings. We were
only giving out like a three of max and we've already given out those to people, but we'll
send you the recording for this live Arunava. So you don't need to worry about that, but also
tell him and let everyone know we are going to be doing a giveaway on Friday and we're going to be
giving away the whole stack of the last five lives. And we're going to get to, you know,
we should do, let's do two, let's do two. We're going to give two people the full stack and then
we could even maybe we could give one away just to somebody in this group. So keep an eye out.
If you're not in the free group, we're going to be giving away the last five recordings.
And guys, we're purposely doing this because people aren't taking this like as serious as
we want them to for the amount of time and effort we guys, we literally have full-time
people monitoring that group that are getting paid. Like go find another Facebook group that
has a paid person, multiple paid people monitoring a free group. What do we have? Three people that
are employed full-time by me that are running that group plus me, plus you. I mean, it's insane. So
anyway, keep going. Yeah, for sure. And so Ed said, do you always go for a $1,000 website rental
price tag? Like is the minimum. When I first started, no, I accepted my first, it was like
$600. But ever since I got my first thousand dollars, yeah, it's unless I, I don't even know
last time I did less than a thousand. A thousand is kind of like the starting point. And that's
before this thing inflated. So I would, you guys should not be charging anything less than a thousand.
You're crazy too. And some of you guys are like, well, if you can't fathom charging a thousand,
you're the wrong niche. Right. There's just too many opportunities, like opportunity costs.
A hundred percent. Theo says, what will you do if you had to do Legion only in your state, Utah,
for scale, stay narrow or go wide? Well, I would ask why that, why you, so he's asked, he's from
France, right? Theo, yeah, pretty sure. Okay. So he's basically asking that because he's in France.
He's in France. He wants to target France. Okay. So that's, that's the real question is if I was
going to do it in France. So what I would do is I would just do the same thing. I would go and figure
out like, Hey, how can I go into two to three really? Well, my first, as my advice was go pick
one niche, get your first two to three deals in the one niche. And then from there become the expert
in that and then branch out into two to three niches and go countrywide. Now, if you're just
going to stick in France and I'm guessing because he's thinking there's a language barrier, by the
way, guys, if you think that there's an accent barrier, language barrier, whatever, it's not,
it's not what you think. If you can get them leads up front, you can go into any country in the world
just so you know. But I know what you're asking this. So what I would say is for your situation,
this is why I said it's not black and white. You might have to go into a few more niches
than two to three. You might have to be in five. So that's going to be a little bit challenging
because you're going to have to be the expert of five. But if you're choosing to only stick
into France, then that that might be the case. So that'd be my answer.
Awesome. That makes sense. OK. And then Ed said this might be for another day, but please briefly
touch on picking a city. You've also done a couple of YouTube lives on this that are they are different
from the ones we just did with the zoom lives here. But those are also just other angles at
looking at the diamond that is making a city. Yeah. And I'll give I'll give two or three things.
And then also, again, just as a reminder, as I said before, like even with these two or three
things, each one of these things, I could talk for an hour plus on. So I'm going to get the two
or three things, Ed. But just so you know, this is again, I don't know if you were on at the
beginning when I gave the example of the trainer. It's like the purpose of these lives is to give
you enough to get started. And now you're asking the right questions right now. You're like, OK.
And once you get into this, Aaron, you probably realize this, too, right? It's like when you
hear the concept, like, yeah, that's easy. I remember hearing the first podcast on this.
I'm like, yeah, for sure. And I even went, dude, I even went to Weebly and I was like,
what do I do? And then I was like, how do I get a free? And I got a Google voice number.
And then after I wasted like four hours, I'm like, yeah, let me just get the blueprint. Let
me go find somebody that's teaching this. But like, you don't really know how much you don't
know until you start getting into this. And that's the whole point, guys. I want you to get in.
The first step is the hardest. It's the hardest to put on your gym shoes and get to the freaking gym.
And then you could figure everything else out. So my goal is to inspire you to get started.
And then if you guys want to either spend the next five years at the gym, try to figure
everything out, asking this person, ask that person, watching YouTube video, following this,
following that, doing this, make a mistake, not losing weight. That's cool. That's one way.
Or you can just go to the guy that looks how you want to look or the girl looks how you want to
look, say, hey, what's your what's your feet? Can you just tell me what to eat, what to train,
how to rest? Well, that's it. So that said, guys, city, it has nothing to do with population,
has everything to do with volume, volume versus competition. I typically like to go into the
smallest cities possible with adequate search volume. And the only reason I say that is
typically speaking, the smaller the city, the lower the competition, not always.
Other than that, I stay out of certain states.
If cities near me fit the bill, I love it because heck, I can drive to them. I can drop the fact
that I'm local. I have a local phone number. I also like to look at trends. I like to make sure
like, hey, for example, I'm in Dubai right now. I could tell you right now, for those of you that
want to test out new countries, Dubai is a country. It's not getting less popular. It's only getting
more popular. And there's certain cities in states, Los Angeles is not getting more popular.
People aren't getting more interested in Los Angeles. I'm telling you that right now.
So these are some of the factors from a high overview that I like to look at. We went into
detail that week. Also as a side note, anyone that's on this call that's in Digital Landlords,
this entire library is inside of the training as well. And Aaron, can you make sure that we
let Isaac know to put this library inside of the training? Yeah, for sure. I see Stephanie's answer.
We'll definitely get you taken care of there. What's up, Stephanie? Good to see you, Stephanie.
Any other questions? Yeah, so we got some really good ones. And actually, I'll take a screenshot
for you next so we can address things like if you want to do YouTube videos, but we won't be
able to probably get to them all. Okay. Let's rapid fire for the next three minutes.
Yeah, let's do it. So what is the maximum amount, Theo says, what is the maximum amount
billed per month for a single service for a business owner? Max? I had for a single service
or a single site, because I've charged as much as like $3,000 per month for one single website,
one client. But I've also had clients that they pay me $1,000 to $2,000 per location and I've
expanded and grown them to $30,000 a month. I've done both. So there's no max. It just depends on
the niche. There's a niche called pole barns, I think it's called. I've never done it. It's like
metal buildings or it's like a specific type of metal building. I don't even know what it is. And
we have one of our students that's doing it and he was charging like $5,000 a month retainers
because they're such big jobs. So there's no max. That's the beautiful thing. That's the beautiful
thing. Just be careful you don't sell out of your own wallet. To you, if $5,000 a month seems like
a lot, that doesn't mean it's a lot for everybody. $5,000 a month doesn't scare me because I'd spend
that on one person that's consulting us on one thing inside of our business right now. But to
you, because you're just starting, that might be your entire salary. So don't sell out of your own
wallet. Remember that that's not expensive to everybody. Keep going.
For sure. This one I like super easy from Arunava. He says, for charging $1,000 a month,
that means I need to choose high ticket boring niches. The response would be yes. So like,
okay, like it's, it's easy to get 10 concrete leaves and get like 50 plumbing or towing weights.
Why, why, why, yeah, why, why? Just make it easy.
Yeah. And then also the, I missed this one. Shane says, do you feel that the tried and true niches,
concrete tree service, et cetera, are saturated or will get saturated?
I think that they're more saturated than they were, but I think there's so many deals. Like
I'm going to give you an example. I just made a YouTube video. By the way, if you guys aren't
subscribed to me on YouTube, I do completely different content than I do in my free groups.
It's, and I'm just saying that because I like, I put, I made a YouTube video before I got on this.
I was making a YouTube video showing a niche literally like a couple of days ago.
I was showing Bentonville concrete. In fact, go guys, go look at this video. It's like my last
uploaded video, second to last uploaded video. And I've made $46,000 from this one website.
And as I'm doing the freaking live video, the second person that's ranked is a lead generator.
And instead of being pissed, I was like, cool. Somebody saw my videos, went and did the research
and realized that there's another opportunity to come in, rank a website and go get a client.
So are you going to run into more lead generators? Yes. Is there still deals? Yes. Would I go into,
would I focus solely on concrete after we've talked about it for two years?
I don't know. Maybe, maybe not, but there's masonry, there's artificial grass, there's
duck cleaning, there's freaking pole barns, there's metal buildings. Like I'm breaking down new
niches all the time inside of digital landlords, Aaron. And there's always new stuff that's coming
up that works. So keep going. A hundred percent last comment. This isn't really a question,
but a comment that we can probably wrap it up. But I said, please do a call on getting clients.
So it sounds like really the sales process, specifically the sales call.
Yeah. A hundred percent. That would be that we do. We have a training on that. It's about
four hours worth of training. So it's like, that's, that's, that is the whole problem. That is the,
that is the most important part. And I'm only saying this because a lot of people think
it's two things, picking the right city and niche and getting the client,
all the stuff in between is easy. Get building a website, ranking it on Google, all the stuff that
you think I need to get tech. Dude, that stuff's easy. Aaron, can you back me up on this? Like
that's the stuff. There's a thousand trainings on how to rank a website. Pick a good city and you
don't even have to be that good. That's, that's the truth. You like, that's literally the game,
right? Like you want to go and like make money on a house, go find the house that's completely
marked way under it's undervalued and go sell it for the value. So the value it's actually
worth, that's the easiest way to make money. Like, so if you can pick, figure out a pick a
city and niche properly, and you know, the sales process, that's the whole game. But to let you
know at the sales process is not just call client there. It's very systematic. There's things you
need to say. There's people you need to target. There's strategy behind it. There's certain ways
to pass over the leads. There's scripts that, yeah, you don't have to know it. You can, you
could stumble your way to a deal, but that's why I do what I do. That's why we, we built what we
built. And so we'll get to that, but it's probably going to be in like Q3 of next year, or maybe it's
Q1 of next year. I don't know. Again, the whole purpose of this is to get you guys to take your
first step, but I love the questions. Ed's got good questions. Ed has really good questions. I,
is Ed in Digital Landlords? I'm trying to remember. He's not. I definitely know he's not in the
Facebook group. I'm just giving you a hard time, bro. I love your questions. They're, they're,
they're great questions. They're all the questions you should be asking. It's why I'm curious. So
is there anything else? Maybe we could do one or two more. Yeah. So Ed also does say,
have you done revenue share? No. Why would I do revenue share? So I can, so that there's like,
if I could do flat fee, why would I do revenue share? Yeah. It seems like with revenue share,
like the only way it works is if you have like a super quality business owner who's good at their
job and there's also honest. And the only problem with that is it's not a way to scale because you
can't learn that until you've worked with them for a while. The only time I'm doing revenue share is
if it's a family member or a friend that I'm doing it as a favor or as a bigger move. That's
the only way I'd never do revenue share. I'll never do commission and I'll never do paper lead
again because why, why, why, if it takes five extra seconds, then why I want, if you guys,
by the way, follow me on Instagram. Lately, I've been showing my Stripe account. I just did today.
I love waking up and seeing at five 35 this morning. I made 150 bucks. It's not a lot,
but you know what? I made 150 bucks while I was on sleepy time. That's sexy to me. I love that. I
don't care if it's $5. I didn't have to work for that. It was done. It was time. Just do one more
more. Yeah. Awesome. I think I'm looking through these. I think that is actually it. I hope I'm
not missing a comment. We did it, dude. We did it. Beautiful. That was good. That was beautiful.
Okay. So what we're going to do guys, thank you guys for being on the call. Once again, Aaron,
real quick, go ahead and drop that link one more time for digital landlords. I have no shame in
doing that only because I, I want you guys to understand this is just like with your business
owners. If you're going to give them free leads, the reason you're doing, you're giving them free
leads is to ultimately lead them to working with you. I'm, I'm on this call because I want to work
with you guys. Like I'm not here to pretend that like this is some kind of like volunteer service.
I make money. I like money. You should too. We can all make money and that's great. I am giving you
this live training because I want to earn your business and you might have to get on a couple
of these before you realize, Hey, I'm just, I'm just kicking the can down the road. But for those
of you that value your time, like I did, or they're in a situation that need to get going,
get serious about life and freaking start making some money and realize that like you can wake up
tomorrow and get hit by a freaking bus and your family's not taken care of and you need to leave
them assets. There you go. So Aaron, drop that one more time. Everyone that was on this call,
that kept their camera on, you guys are going to get a message from Donnie. Is it going to be Donnie
Dre? Yeah, it's going to be Donnie. Donnie Dre is going to reach out, give you our digital resource.
And if I were you guys, I'd keep a little folder, nicely tucked folder. And we're going to keep
giving you guys as incredible value. And the last thing I want to say is I wrap this up guys,
look at what I'm doing on this call and do it for your clients. Go and give the business owners,
you're trying to earn their business so much value. Guys, I guarantee that you could go,
like what I gave you today is 10 times better than what you're going to get from a Udemy course that
you would have spent 50 bucks on or a hundred bucks on or what, I don't even know what it is.
I don't, I've never bought any of that stuff. I promise you the experience I have and the value
I gave you and including this digital resource, you got more value than you would have from paid
stuff. Go do that for your business owners and they will come to you. They will want to work
with you and they will want to stay working with you and grow with you. And that's how you become
a millionaire in this business. So that said, Aaron, anything else? No, that's good. Okay,
I'm out. See you guys next week. Bye.